KATE: Good afternoon,
everyone.
Authors at Google New York is
pleased to welcome Simon
Winchester today.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
Thanks, Kate.
One day, about two years ago
now, I got a telephone call
from a friend of mine in London
who runs a company
called Touch Press, which you
may be familiar with some of
their products.
They did an app on the elements,
which was actually
bundled with the first iPads,
and then they did one on the
solar system, and they've done
all sorts of things since.
And Max said, have you
seen the story in
today's Daily Mail?
As I'm sure you probably know,
especially if there are any
Brits in the audience, the
Mail is the most popular
English newspaper on the
web in the world.
It is also probably the most
irresponsible and inaccurate
and ludicrously sensational
newspaper in the world as
well, but it's nonetheless
compelling reading.
And they had a story, said Max,
on that particular day
about an amazing--
or Max thought he was
an amazing fellow--
called Alan Dudley who lives in
Coventry in England, which
is probably one of
the most dreary
cities in Western Europe.
And he had amassed, according to
the Daily Mail story, what
was probably the largest
collection of skulls anywhere
in the world.
Would I, said Max,
go and see him?
Because it was a possibility, he
thought, that we could turn
his collection into an app
that would be amusing and
interesting and indeed
useful for the iPad.
So I flew over to London and
rented a car and drove up to
Coventry, and came to this
extremely ordinary street of
semi detached pebbled
ash covered
houses, utterly anonymous.
And indeed, the first house I
went to, which I thought was
his house, wasn't.
And even though the fellow was
next door, he had no idea who
Alan Dudley was.
And I said, but he is the owner
of what is essentially
the largest collection of skulls
in the world, and he's
lived there for 35 years.
And he said, well, I've never
met him, because the English
are very private people.
So clearly, this obsession of
Alan's was very private.
And anyway, I knocked on his
door and eventually saw this
astonishing collection of his.
First of all, it never ceases
to surprise me the amazing
jobs that people have.
His, and he had done this for
the previous 25 years--
Coventry is a great motor car
building city, and for the
past quarter century, Alan has
been the person who selected
the veneers that are put
on the dashboards of
Jaguar motor cars.
So if any of you have or aspire
to have a Jaguar, and
you sit down, and you see this
beautiful bold wood walnut
dashboard, that walnut
would have been
chosen by Alan Dudley.
So that's what he does in
his daytime occupation.
But for most of his adult
life, he's also, in the
evening, collected skulls.
And it began like this.
I'll just show you his first.
What happened was, when
he was about 18--
I mean, like most children,
in England anyway, and
increasingly because of PBS
people here, he had been
obsessed with David Attenborough
and wildlife, and
he had collected birds' eggs and
salamanders and newts and
tadpoles and frogs and things.
But then one day, when he was
17 or 18, he saw beside the
road, slung across a fence, the
carcass of a fox, which
had clearly been knocked down
in a traffic accident.
And he was suddenly seized with
the idea that perhaps he
should take this fox home and
stuff it-- that he should
become an amateur taxidermist.
So he brought it home, an
enormous beautiful red thing,
and looked at it more carefully,
and found it had
actually been badly hurt
in the accident--
ribs smashed, and a big gash
in its side, and it wasn't
amenable, really, to being
stuffed, at least not by the
skills he then had.
And then he had the sudden
thought that probably most of
you in this room would
not have, and I
certainly wouldn't have--
he thought, well, why don't I
cut off its head and collect
its skull--
prepare its skull?
So he did that.
And not much of what I'm going
to say is going to be terribly
macabre, other than obviously,
the subject as a whole, but
what he did was he took his pen
knife, and he scraped off
the fur, and he scraped off the
muscles and excised the
eyes and the tongue and so
forth, and came up with this,
which is the first skull he ever
collected, which is the
skull of a red fox.
And I don't have a pointer.
I'm sure I could be given one,
but I don't really need one,
because I just very briefly
will point out the salient
features of a skull.
A skull is essentially composed
of about 26 bones.
Two major parts--
the upper part, which is the
cranium, that holds the
brain-- the most important
function-- and most of the
sense organs.
And then the lower part, which
is the mandible, which is the
lower part of the jaw.
And when the mandible and the
cranium are brought together,
the creature bites,
and so forth.
And the relevant
parts to see--
you can see the eye sockets
there, then beneath them,
sticking out-- actually, if you
look at this view, you see
them sticking out like wings.
They're called the
zygomatic arches.
We have them.
All animals with skulls
have them.
They're our cheeks--
our cheekbones.
At the very top, you
can sort of see a
ridge at the very top.
That's called the sagittal
ridge, and attached to that
are the muscles which cause the
mandible to open and close.
So an animal like a tiger, which
has very powerful jaws,
has a very well developed
sagittal ridge.
Just below it, you
see these bulges.
You can see it on the left hand
side of the screen there.
That's the auditory bullae.
That's what holds all
the material that's
connected with hearing.
So an animal that hears very
well, like a hare a or rabbit
or a deer, will have
a very advanced and
enormous auditory bulla.
So that's basically it.
Zygomatic arches, cranium, brain
case, of course, most of
the top of it.
And Alan was enraptured by this,
and quite rightly so,
because I think you must agree
that once cleaned up, it is a
beautiful thing.
So he decided to collect
more and more and more.
And the first, just to give you
a very brief look at some
of the others to show that--
I think the next one was a newt
that he collected, which
is much the same,
except zygomatic
arch is much smaller.
It doesn't want to hear very
much, so its auditory bullae
aren't particularly developed.
On the other hand, it's got very
big eye sockets, because
newts need to see.
And the teeth, very much smaller
and more numerous.
But the basic structure
is the same.
If you go to something that
looks wildly different, like
this fire fish here, I mean,
totally different.
But yet, not different.
When you look at it in a meta
sense, the broad structure is
essentially the same.
So he had developed
this obsession.
And in the early days, he was
doing what I described.
He was scraping, in this case,
obviously, the scales off, and
the meat, and so forth,
with a knife.
But that's unsatisfactory,
and you're likely
to damage the skull.
So he experimented with all
sorts of ways of removing the
outer material and leaving
just the bones.
And the traditional
way is to put in--
and this will sound
slightly macabre--
put the skull in among a lot of
maggots, and they will chew
the flesh away.
Or domestic beetles do
much the same thing.
But the problem with these
maggots and beetles, if you're
serious about skull collecting,
is that in their
frenzy of eating, they sort of
elbow each other out of the
way and do considerable damage
to the very delicate bones
that are inside a skull.
For instance, within the nose
of an animal that has a very
well developed olfactory sense,
there are very, very
fine wafer thin bones, which
these hungry maggots will
displace in their frenzy
to eat away the flesh.
And so he came up, in the end,
with the very, very basic but
rather lengthy process, which
will be guaranteed to remove
away the flesh without any risk
to the bones underneath,
and that's called cold
water maceration.
Basically, you put the skull
into a bucket of cold water
and leave it for about six
months, and the bacteria in
the water and bacteria that
settle on the surface of the
water, they will do
the job for you.
But unfortunately, the byproduct
of this is water
which becomes extraordinarily
smelly.
I mean, it is really
disgusting.
And the fact that in his mid
20s, his garden shed and his
bedroom was beginning to fill up
with buckets of very, very
smelly water with unpleasant
objects slowly rotting inside
them was one of the factors,
I think, which caused Mrs.
Dudley to leave Alan.
And so in his late 20s, Mr.
Dudley, selecting his veneers
in a heroic manner, was
nonetheless doing so as a
bachelor, his wife having gone
off with somebody else.
And he was alone in his house
in Coventry with lots of
buckets of black water,
and lots of skulls.
But he was an optimistic chap,
and he said, well, this at
least frees up a bedroom.
And this was what he indeed used
to display his skulls.
And this is the collection in
the bedroom of his very modest
house in Coventry.
And as you can see, he did do
a bit of amateur taxidermy,
but his greatest interest was
in the skulls beneath.
And there is the door
through which Mrs.
Dudley used to come.
And there, basically--
there are more out of the
field of view-- but the
central part of a collection
which is world class.
I mean, mammals, there are only
58,000 species in the
tens of millions of species--
that's a hippopotamus in the
middle, incidentally--
which have skulls.
And they're divided, these
chordates, into five classes--
the mammals, the birds, the
fish, the reptiles, and the
amphibians.
And Alan has type examples of
sort of everything within
these five major classes
of chordates.
So it is a world class
collection, and people come to
him offering him creatures
that he might
like to put in it.
Most of his skulls these
days come from zoos.
So what happens generally is
that if a zoo has got a
hippopotamus which isn't feeling
terribly well, they'll
ring up Alan and say, if you
bide your time a few weeks, we
can probably let you have
a hippopotamus skull.
And so he will then go up and
get the hippopotamus and take
off its head, and put it in
obviously not a bucket, but an
enormous container of water, and
eventually it will turn up
in his collection.
So you can see he's not
much of a prospect for
eHarmony and so forth.
But nonetheless, he has made
this extraordinary
amassment of skulls.
And this is the reason--
well, it's the ultimate reason
that we came to see him.
But the proximate reason we came
to see him was because of
what the Daily Mail
story said.
And the reason he was in the
Daily Mail was not simply
because he had got a marvelous
collection, but because he was
in trouble with the police.
And what had happened was that,
you know, he's a kindly,
decent human being, but his
collecting zeal had very
occasionally got the better of
him, and he had collected, it
turns out, one or two things
that he ought not to have had.
And this led to--
I think it was the morning of
the 28th of March in 2008, 7
o'clock in the morning,
hammering on his door, and he
went down in his dressing gown
and opened the door to find
four policemen standing there.
Two uniformed policemen, in case
the situation got ugly,
which clearly it wasn't going
to do, because he's not that
sort of a chap.
And a man who had come all the
way down from Edinburgh, from
essentially the wildlife police,
who are, for some
reason, based in
Scotland, where
there's very little wildlife.
And someone from the
customs and excise.
And they had been tracking the
internet and had noticed that
he had been trading, or
at least purchasing--
because he doesn't sell very
many of his skulls.
He's not a trader, he's
a collector--
creatures that are banned
under the CITES, the
convention banning the
internet traffic
of endangered species.
And I think the particular ones
that he was involved with
was a loggerhead turtle, some
particular type of penguin, a
Siberian tiger, and I think the
one that they were most
cross about was a howler
monkey from Ecuador.
The chap in Edinburgh had seen
three trades that had occurred
recently in howler monkeys,
which are absolutely
protected, and two of them, the
policeman had noticed, had
bullet holes in their skulls,
where they had presumably been
hunted by Ecuadorians willing
to trade them.
The one that Alan had got did
not have a bullet hole, but
nonetheless, simply by having
it-- by having bought it-- he
was, in the view of the
prosecuting authorities,
guilty of having transgressed
this law.
So they said, I'm terribly
sorry, Mr. Dudley.
We're going to have to arrest
you formally, charge you with
a breach of the CITES
convention.
And so they put crime scene
tape over his bedroom--
the former Mrs. Dudley's
bedroom--
and they affixed to his leg--
I can probably show you this
immediately, yes, that.
Not particularly
elegant device.
Not a particularly elegant shoe,
either, but it's one of
these things that Martha
Stewart wore.
And it was very carefully
calibrated.
He had to wear it
until the trial.
He wasn't allowed to leave the
city of Coventry, which I'm
sure was something that most
people would wish to do.
But more specifically, it was
so finely calibrated he
couldn't go into his
own bedroom where
the collection was.
So when we visited him, or when
I first visited him, he
would invite me into his kitchen
for a cup of tea, and
we'd go upstairs.
But then, there was the yellow
crime scene tape over that
door, and he said, I'm afraid
I can't go in there.
But on the other hand, you
can, and if you hand me
things, I can tell you
what they are.
So he eventually did appear in
court, and he pleaded guilty,
because he clearly had bought
the howler monkey and the
penguin and the Siberian
tiger.
But he was clearly not bent on
any profuse and profound bout
of illegality.
And the judge--
well, the judge sentenced
him to prison.
Two years, but a suspended
sentence.
So, provided he didn't do
anything bad again, he'd be
free to go.
And they fined him 2,000 pounds,
and they confiscated
the five offending animal skulls
and then let him go.
And that, of course, was
in the press as well.
So what we decided to do was
to first of all, in making
this app, look at
his collection.
And although there's this
fancy title page, the
collection is, as I say, about
3,000 skulls, and they're
arranged in the five classes--
mammals, birds, fishes,
reptiles, and amphibians.
So these are all sortable.
We just chose the 300 or
so that we thought were
interesting and illustrative.
And the way each one is done
is that if you take any
particular one--
perhaps not a fish.
How about this nice armadillo?
The skull itself is there
on the right.
If you click it, you
can expand it.
You can look at it in
3D, right to left,
if you've got glasses.
Left to right if you haven't
got glasses.
And also, the wireless
connection here, if it was
automatic, then it'll come up.
But if you click on this little
star-- it may not--
that goes to Wolfram Alpha,
which will give you, if it
computes it correctly, a full
taxonomic description of
Cordylus cataphractus, which
is this armadillo.
But I think perhaps, because I
haven't set up wireless, it's
not going to.
But it ultimately does, and it's
very sophisticated and
very much in depth.
So this is an enormously
potentially very, very useful
tour d'horizon of this
remarkable collection.
I mean, some of these things are
just stunningly beautiful.
I love this skull--
so delicate, so lovely.
And you can see where
Alan's coming from.
But the reason they asked me to
come along and be involved
in this project is not because
I'm particularly knowledgeable
about skulls, although oddly
enough, I did have some
intimacy with them, because when
I left school, like many
English people, I took a year
or so off between leaving
school and going up
to university.
So I had about 15 months,
and I wanted to come
over to this country.
So to earn the money to buy me
passage on a ship across the
Atlantic, I worked for a number
of months in a mortuary
in North London.
And the principal job was
to cut up bodies.
And one of them, you had to take
off the top of the skull
to weigh the brain
and so forth.
But also, one of the teaching
hospitals in London had a--
not a scam going, but an
arrangement that if people
like me would remove the
pituitary from the back of the
brain and put them in a jar, for
every 100 pituitaries you
got, you'd be given, I think,
five pounds or something.
So I became, as a consequence
of that, reasonably
knowledgeable of the human
skull, although not of these
animal skulls.
But became quite interested in
why we as a species are more
interested in the skull than
in any of the other 220 odd
bones that make up
the human body.
And it's axiomatic that right
from day one, of all the
various bones that you see
preserved in graves and
middens and so forth, it is the
skull that occupies the
pride of place.
I mean, it's not the femur,
despite it being the longest
bone in the body.
It's not the ribcage, despite
that it protects the
heart and the lungs.
It's not the pelvis, which, in
most creatures, is from which
life springs.
It is the head.
The thing that encased this
brain matter, which 5,000
years ago, no one really had
much of a clue as to
what the brain did.
But there was the assumption
that the personality or the
soul, if I can put it that way,
of its owner was probably
housed in the head.
And so the head was given
particular veneration, and you
go to almost any grave site, and
it is the skull that is in
pride of place.
So the Touch Press people came
to me and said, we're going to
photograph all these skulls.
And incidentally, I should say
that the way it was done was
quite technically interesting.
They had a photographer called
Nick Mann come over from
Chicago to photograph each of
these skulls on a black
turntable with a black
velvet background.
And he turned them half
a degree at a time.
So one rotation was 720 stops.
And at each point, he would
photograph it in very, very
multi-pixelated form, and at
the end of the day, would
enable it, therefore, to be
turned and expanded in the way
you've seen.
So we're not going to involve
you, Simon Winchester, in
this, but can you write a series
of essays on why we're
so interested in skulls, and
how skulls generally have
infiltrated human society
and human culture?
So I thought what I'd do now,
just very briefly, is to look
at a couple of areas in which
the skull has infiltrated
human society.
And I'll start off with the
skull in art, because it's
more visually interesting.
So as you can see, incidentally,
where it says
human here-- this is a
classic human skull--
if you'll remember when I showed
you the armadillo and
the other creatures, that they
always show the creature from
which the skull came.
There's a sort of type example
of an armadillo, type example
of a fire fish.
Well, the type example
of the human, believe
it or not, is me.
So I have one small distinction
that in an app,
I'm regarded as a typical
human, and I think it's
largely because more of my skull
is visible than in most
not so challenged as I am.
But let us have a
look briefly.
All sorts of artists, of
course, drew skulls.
Leonardo, Durer--
Durer was very big on skulls.
There on the right, there are
lots and lots of his.
Then you get these extraordinary
things that look
almost like skulls anyway,
and are manipulated
to become more so.
This is agate, I think,
from China.
This is Van Gogh, and presumably
what happens if you
smoke too much.
This is a beautiful thing.
I think it's in the British
Museum in London, this
exquisite malachite skull with
these pyrite eyes and little
fragments of amethyst, and it's
got leather straps that
you put it on your face.
It's very old, and it's
extremely beautiful.
Incidentally, I should
make one remark
about skulls in art.
You may notice, if you go
through this, and indeed the
book, that there is no mention
of what is probably the most
famous artistically rendered
skull, and
that is Damien Hirst's.
It's called For The Love Of God,
mainly because his mother
said to him, for the love of
God, Damien, what are you
going to do next, after he had
produced the cow and the fish
in the formaldehyde
tank and so forth.
And he said, what I'm going to
do is I'm going to buy a human
skull, and I'm going to cover
it in platinum, a very thin
skin of platinum.
Then I'm going to stud that
platinum with 8,500 diamonds,
including a large pink oval
diamond over in the middle of
the forehead.
And I'm going to create, quite
deliberately, the most
expensive piece of
art in the world.
It had no other purpose
other than to
be very, very expensive.
And I might say--
I'm sorry there are these many
parentheses in this, and there
shouldn't be.
But when he went looking for
the skull, he went to an
antique shop in London.
I mean, you shouldn't really be
able to buy human skulls,
for obvious reasons, but
he found a skull.
But he was then told a
story, which is, I
think, quite amusing.
An antique dealer in, I think,
Brighton, was making a big
deal of the fact that
he had a skull of a
former English King.
I think it was Henry II.
Beautiful thing, slightly
discolored, but in perfectly
good condition, and he wanted
several thousand pounds for
it, and someone eventually
agreed to buy for 3,000 pounds
the skull of King Henry II.
So he bought it, and the
merchant packaged it up.
And as he was leaving the shop,
he noticed a similar
looking, but very, very much
smaller skull on a display
table just by the front door.
And he said to the antique store
owner, what is that?
And he said, oh, I'm interested
you asked.
He said, that is also Henry II,
but when he was a baby.
I'm so sorry.
Anyway, back to Damien Hirst.
Damien bought this particular
skull, covered it with the
diamonds and platinum and so
forth, and auctioned it for 56
million pounds, I think.
There were no takers, so he then
had to form a consortium
of his friends and buy it for
25 million pounds, which is
its ultimate shop value,
as it were, and
then put it on display.
And we decided, obviously, that
it should be in this app.
So we approached him, and
he said yes, sure.
So I wrote an essay about Damien
Hirst, and it was a
slightly tongue in cheek essay,
because I'm not a great
fan of his.
But only slightly.
I mean, it was quite polite.
I pulled my punches.
And we photographed, using Nick
Mann's technique, under
very, very high security, armed
guards and all the rest
of it, this beautiful object.
But then Damien saw the essay,
and saw the skull, and I'm not
quite sure which ticked him
off most, but he said, the
skull doesn't glitter enough
when it's turned Obviously, if
it's got thousands of
diamonds, it should.
And we thought it glittered just
as it had when you saw it
in real life.
So they took the files back to
Chicago and wrote some complex
algorithms which you would know
more about than I do,
which added glitter.
And every single one of these
diamonds had the requisite
amount of glitter added to it.
And it was sent back to Damien,
and he said no, it's
still not satisfactory enough.
And so we yanked the whole
thing, shortly, within, I
think, 10 days before the
app was released.
So we were cross with him, he
was cross with us, and so we
like Damien Hirst even less
than we had at first.
So there's no Damien Hirst, and
if you're looking for one,
I'm sorry, but that's
the reason why.
But anyway, moving along, this
is the painting that I find
most interesting in terms
of skulls in art.
You probably recognize it.
Painted in 1538 by
Hans Holbein.
It's called The Ambassadors.
And it is a portrait
commissioned by the chap on
the left, who's called Jean de
Dinteville, who was the French
ambassador to London, or the
Court of St. James, as they
call it, in the 1530s.
And the chap on the right is
called Georges de Selve, who
was his great schoolboy
friend.
They're both in their 20s, even
though they look as if
they're in their 40s, but
they're in their 20s.
Very young, very wealthy
ambassadors, and they were
appointed--
he, Georges de Selve,
was, at the time,
ambassador to Venice.
So they were brought together,
and this was at a time of
phenomenal turmoil in the
Christian church, as you
probably realize.
And this specific--
I can expand this, but it's
not sufficiently good, I
think, on the screen to show
you-- but just by de
Dinteville's left hand
is that cylindrical
thing, which is a calendar.
And you can see, if you look at
it carefully, the precise
date that this painting is
supposed to illustrate, which
is the 4th of April,
I think, 1533--
Good Friday, 1533--
which indicates that it is in
the mind of Holbein that he
wants to make this a
religious painting,
with a religious motif.
And nearly everything in it
is displaying the kind of
turmoil, the schism, that had
already built in the church.
The globe has, at its center,
Rome, suggesting that at a
point in this story, Rome
regarded itself as the center
of the world.
On the other hand, the book, if
you look at it closely, is
the writings of Martin Luther,
who, as you remember, was very
much a Protestant.
And what had happened, of
course, is that this painting
was created at the time that
Henry VIII in England, to
which Jean de Dinteville was
ambassador, had lately divorced.
He had decided to marry Anne
Boleyn, and the Pope, Clement
VII, I think, had this big hissy
fit and decided that the
churches should split up.
So the Church of England was
created, the dissolution of
the monastery was
about to happen.
There was an awful
lot of ferment.
Symbols such as this lute, which
has a broken string--
you can't see it here, but
that's one of the artistic
symbols to suggest ferment.
So although on the surface, this
looks rather an amusing,
rather sedate portrait of two
rather wealthy men, it
actually has a lot more
symbolism within it.
And most significantly of all is
this smear at the bottom of
the picture-- this diagonal
crude smear, which people
understood what it was,
but it remains--
this painting is huge.
It's seven feet by seven feet,
and it's on oak wood.
It's oil on oak, and
it stands in the
National Gallery in London.
And after a while, it is the
smear at the bottom that is
the intriguing thing.
It was asked for by the
commissioner, Jean de
Dinteville.
He said, I want, as many
people wanted in their
commission portraits at the
time, a memento mori, a
reminder of the likelihood
of death.
Because however grand and
covered with ermine and mink I
might be, I am going to die.
And so somehow, you must put
into this painting a reminder
to those who see this
painting in years to
come that we are human.
All flesh is grass, and that
ultimately, I'll die.
And very cleverly, Holbein
put in this.
And you all know, I'm
sure, what it is.
But this device gives
you the ability to
demonstrate what it is.
Because if you swipe this
painting slowly, you can see
that that smear, when seen from
a certain angle, turns
into a skull.
The device as a whole--
the artistic device--
is known as an anamorphosis.
It's the kind of thing you see
on your television screens
when you watch football
players.
They project something which is
distorted if you see it on
the ground, but actually, not
distorted at all when you see
it on your television sets.
So this is also a bit of 16th
century anamorphosis, so much,
much older, and I think a
thing of great beauty.
And it's an illustration of
why these kind of devices,
although I loathe to say it--
my entire career has been based
on ink and paper and
books and so forth--
why this kind of a device can
lend an extraordinary new
dimension to the reading
experience.
So the painting was initially
put at the top of a spiral
staircase, and so simply by
going up the spiral staircase,
you would see this smear change
into a skull, and as
you left it, it would return
to its original, rather
enigmatic state.
So there's an example of one
aspect of the skull in art.
There are many others.
But let's move on to another,
which is the skull in science
and pseudoscience.
This was an area that interested
me a great deal.
Skulls have been misused in
science a great deal,
particularly in America,
oddly enough.
In the latter part of the 19th
century, the US Army collected
a huge number of skulls at Fort
Leavenworth in Kansas and
gave them or loaned them to a
researcher, who created an
entirely new field that he
called craniometry--
the measurement of skulls--
and came up with some ideas that
skulls can be classified
according to--
for instance, a very simple
classification is whether
they're brachiocephalic
or dolichocephalic.
If you look in dogs' world, for
instance, a greyhound with
its long pointed snout is
dolichocephalic, whereas a
bulldog with its smashed up
face is brachiocephalic.
And the researcher and
subsequent researchers came up
with the misguided idea, which
is why I talk about this as
pseudoscience, that within the
human world particularly, the
shape of a skull had some
hierarchical importance.
And for instance, in the 1920s
and '30s, it was said that
Aryans principally have
dolichocephalic skulls,
whereas Jewish people have
brachiocephalic skulls.
And this was seized upon by the
scientists, so called, of
the Third Reich, which was
another way of, if you
measured a person's nose and his
brain case and so forth,
you could come up with the idea
that he had a certain
amount or a large amount of
Jewish DNA, and consequently
was ripe for the concentration
camps.
And similarly, this happened in
the 1940s, '50s, and early
'60s in South Africa, when
craniometry was used as a
basis for determining the finer
subtleties of racial
discrimination during the
whole time of apartheid.
So those were the
sort of serious
and unpleasant aspects.
What I'm going to describe very
briefly here is not so
much a serious side, but a sort
of ludicrous side, which
is the whole science
of phrenology.
This is based on
good science--
the discovery or the
assumption-- it wasn't so much
a discovery-- in the late 19th
century by a couple of Germans
that certain parts of the brain
control certain parts of
what you do.
Thinking, calculation, color
awareness, amativeness, in
other words, how sexually active
you are, at least in
your mind, whether you're
good at arithmetic, and
that kind of thing.
And that you could draw a map
of the brain, showing where
these particular qualities
exist.
That's more or less correct.
What was incorrect, though, was
the thought that if you're
particularly good at let's say
arithmetic, or particularly
sexually arousable, then the
area of your brain where this
is located will expand
massively, and it will push
against the skull and cause
you to have a big bulge in
your skull over the part of
your head immediately over
that part of the brain.
So it would then be possible to,
if you had very delicate
fingers, to run your hands over
a person's head and say,
oh, you have an amazing ability
to calculate, or you
have sexual proclivities which
perhaps go somewhat unchecked.
And a man called Fowler, Lorenzo
Fowler, who drew this
exquisite porcelain model, set
up consulting rooms in London
and invited people to come and
have their proclivities
examined and mapped for two
guineas a time, a considerable
amount of money in the early
part of the 20th century.
I should say that it is complete
nonsense to suggest
that the head expands because
of what happens in the brain
underneath.
I mean, there was a horrible
experiment which rather
illustrated this just a couple
of years ago in London-- also
reported hugely on the front
page of the Daily Mail,
because the word elephant
man, they could
get it into the title.
Six young impoverished students
who lived in North
London had agreed to take part
in an experiment to be
injected with a particular type
of drug manufactured by a
German company.
So they were paid 1,000 pounds
each, I think, to enjoy this.
And they had what's called
a cytokine storm, a huge
allergic reaction which caused
their brain and many of their
internal organs to swell
gigantically.
And it's disgusting.
I mean, I've seen some pictures
of eyes bulging out,
and huge necks, these chaps
in incredible pain.
The Daily Mail immediately said,
one of the girlfriends
said, Mike looks like the
elephant man, so natural
headline for the Mail.
But they were in trouble.
I mean, they were given
massive doses of
antihistamine, and slowly it
quieted down, and they all
lived, and lawsuits, of course,
flew hither and yon.
But the point was that they
suffered pain for the same
reason as a meningitis
patient suffers pain.
Because no matter how much the
brain may swell underneath,
the skull is a very, very solid
object and won't allow
anything to-- certainly nothing
so puny as the soft
gray matter of a brain-- to
push it out of shape.
So there was enormous pressure
inside their heads, and that
was why it was so terribly
painful for them.
So the basis of phrenology
is complete nonsense.
And for instance, this
area of the--
in larger audiences, I would
point to that over the left
eye, where it says
calculation--
that if you have a bulge over
your left eye, you are
particularly clever
with arithmetic.
And statistically--
I don't know what the statistics
are-- but I would
always notice that people would
wipe their hands over
their left eye as I'm
talking to them.
And I would say to them,
I've caught you.
I know what you're doing.
And they would say, no, I
was just wiping my eye--
a tear or something.
But people are still fascinated
by the thought that
bumps in their head might give
a clue to their character,
their soul, their amativeness,
their vitativeness, or their
color sense.
But it was nonsense.
All we do know is that Lorenzo
Fowler made himself a great
deal of money.
He published, I think, two
million copies of the pamphlet
showing this map, and left
behind this legacy, which
you'll find in many antique
shops, of these really rather
charming porcelain models
of the brain.
The person, oddly enough, who
discovered or wrote that it
was fraudulent was another
doctor-- a 19th
century London doctor--
and that was Peter Mark Roget,
of Roget's Thesaurus.
He, among many things, one of
them being he was one of the
first people to realize the
invention of a shutter that
would allow for motion
pictures to be taken.
But he was also interested in
the brain, and he realized
that what Lorenzo Fowler had
come up with was nonsense, and
published a paper saying this
is all bunkum, and no one
should take phrenology
at all seriously.
And such was the standing of
Roget in London that he
managed to destroy Fowler, who
promptly left town and went to
live in Paris, I think, for
the rest of his days.
It's interesting that if you
look at Roget's Thesaurus
today, you'll see that he,
Roget, had the last word,
because it's listed now with
astrology and mesmerism and so
forth as just being the
stuff of charlatanism.
So I'm looking at my watch, and
I will only talk about one
further example, and
leave a fourth for
perhaps another occasion.
But this refers to someone
probably you'll all recognize.
This fellow, who I always think
looks a bit like Hitler.
And this is Piltdown Man.
This is one of the most
famous skulls ever.
And the story of Piltdown Man
came about in 1908, when a man
called Charles Dawson, who was
a very flamboyant solicitor--
a lawyer who lived in Sussex,
south of London--
quite wealthy, very
self aggrandizing.
If you see photographs of him,
he's wearing a tricorn hat,
which was a very unusual thing
to wear in the 20th century,
and velvet knee britches, and
extraordinary clothing.
He was a man of great ambition
and many interests.
And this was one that
got away with him.
He was out walking one day in
1908, and he walked beside a
quarry a couple of miles from
his house, near the village of
Piltdown, and found a number of
fragments of the cranium of
something that looked like if
not a human, then a humanoid.
It was a smaller cranium
than normal--
Henry II as a child, maybe--
and the point was that the
opening at the back, where it
connects with the spinal cord,
was of a size that suggested
that it had a much smaller brain
than a hominid of that
size should have.
So it was clearly, in his view,
a primitive hominid, but
it was, nonetheless, man-like.
1908.
What, that's half a century
since Darwin had published On
the Origin of Species.
The biological anthropological
world was in ferment about the
origin of man-- the realization
that man had
descended, in some fashion,
from the ape world.
Teilhard de Chardin in China
had found Peking Man.
Various links to antiquity
were being discovered.
But what was missing was
the missing link--
a creature that showed, beyond
all possibility of
contradiction, that we had
descended from apes.
And so we wanted something that
was half man, half ape.
In discovering this, Dawson
thought maybe
this could be it.
So he took the fragments up to
London, to the head of the
geological department of the
British Museum, a man of
towering reputation and
rectitude called Arthur Smith
Woodward, and said,
have a look.
I found these in my quarry.
The quarry was gravel,
Pleistocene,
920,000 years old.
So everything fitted.
In the very primitive view of
human evolution at the time,
this could be where the
missing link was.
And so the two of them then went
down to the quarry, and
for the next couple of years,
they looked around for
evidence that might create
a full skull.
And in the end, they found a
jawbone, a mandible, and they
found a number of teeth.
And they put them all together,
and they fitted, and
they had one of these epiphanic
moments that in the
end caused Arthur Smith
Woodward, who, as I say, had
an extraordinary reputation,
to publish a paper and
announce, in 1912--
so four years after Dawson had
found the first pieces--
that they had found
the missing link.
It was to be called Eoanthropus,
early man,
dawsoni, after Charles Dawson,
who had found it.
And the world was set
alight by this.
The missing link had at last
been discovered, and the most
wonderful thing about it, at
least from the point of view
of both Smith and Dawson, was
that, incontrovertibly, the
missing link was
an Englishman.
He was a Sussex country
gentleman.
I mean, what could be better
and more satisfying for the
world of early geology, early
anthropology, than that?
And so, for many years, that
was the situation.
This Piltdown man was
given pride of place
in the British Museum.
And in due course, Woodward
died, and then Dawson died in
about 1920, I think.
Huge monument, still stands, put
outside where he used to
live, and by the quarry where
these fragments were found.
And there, the matter
might have remained.
Except, of course, it didn't,
because other
objects were found--
other allegedly missing links of
more provable veracity were
discovered.
And then, in the 1950s, someone
realized that bones
that have been buried for a very
long time absorb from the
earth in which they're
buried fluorine.
So to find out if these were
real, because there was a
suspicion that there was
something awry about it, they
needed to be tested.
And so the British Museum, with
some reluctance, agreed
that they could be tested
non-destructively, for the
presence of fluorine,
and they had no
fluorine in them at all.
And then the whole story
began to fall apart.
Because it turned out that the
cranium, which was quite old
but not very old, but from a
young child, was from Germany,
and had been purchased.
The mandible was that of an
orangutan from Sarawak that
had been stained with potassium
bichromate to give
it the appropriate color.
And the teeth, when looked at
under a microscope, which they
hadn't been in 1912, all had
tiny fragments of metal,
showing that they'd been filed
down to the shape which
suggested that the creature
had a more exotic appetite
than a primitive creature
should have had.
And so one by one, the pillars
on which this creature's
existence as the missing link
had rested were knocked away,
and it was realized that it was,
in fact, a very clever--
actually not very clever, but a
very comprehensive forgery.
But the question was, who had
perpetrated the forgery?
Who had done such a thing?
Well, the initial thought was
one of Dawson's neighbors, who
was Arthur Conan Doyle, who
was always up to cunning
practical jokes and things,
and maybe it was him.
But no, there wasn't sufficient
evidence.
Teilhard de Chardin, who had a
sort of dog in this fight, was
thought possibly to have done
something, but no, that was
discounted.
Woodward, no one thought.
I mean, this was a man who
worked for the British Museum
for 42 years.
Didn't take a single day off in
his entire life, except for
one morning off, when he broke
his arm, and he went back to
work that afternoon.
So he was a pillar of decency
and rectitude.
Everything pointed to
Dawson himself.
And so mercifully, his house
was still in existence, and
there were relatives
living there.
And they went upstairs into a
lumber room, and they found
that his entire life, at least
the life of his pastimes, his
biological ambitions
and so forth, was
just a tissue of forgeries.
There were, I think, 32 objects
in there that were
complete forgeries.
A Chinese brass urn, which was
neither Chinese nor brass.
An elephant's tusk--
I think it was a shovel or
something which had clearly
been cut with a band saw and
sanded down with sandpaper.
The whole thing was
just nonsense.
The New York Times realized the
analogy, he was the Jason
Blair of 20th century biology.
And this poor skull, Piltdown
Man, rather elegant creature,
was now taken off its pedestal
at the front of the British
Museum and moved to a storehouse
at the back, and
can only be seen by special
application.
I won't tell the fourth story,
because we don't have enough
time, but I'll simply
say one thing, which
is that Alan Dudley--
I asked him once if there was
a fire which burned down his
house, which one object of all
these very beautiful objects
would he seize to protect?
And he said it would be this
rather strange thing--
a two headed cow, which he was
given many years ago, which
required an extremely big bucket
for the cold water
maceration.
That, despite all the beauties
of the lizards and the birds
and the various penguins he's
got, is both legal and, in his
view, utterly beautiful.
So there we are.
I'm happy to answer any
questions if you like.
I could go on about this for a
very long time, but you've all
got to go back to
work, I'm sure.
But thank you very much indeed,
and if I can answer
any questions, I'll
do my best.
AUDIENCE: I noticed when you
showed us the fox's skull
earlier that there are these two
holes that are below the
eye sockets, but they're
not the nose.
And I couldn't help but
wonder what those are.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Let
me have a look.
And it's at this point that I
may have to say, but I'm not
an expert on foxes.
But that was a European fox,
I think, wasn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You said it was the first one.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Yeah.
It was indeed the first one.
OK, let me find him.
Oh, there he is.
European red fox.
What are those?
Oh, yes.
Very interesting.
What do you think they are?
I have no idea.
They're jolly nice, though.
I mean, what are those things
on its mandible as well?
I mean, those little holes?
All I can say is that this is
what makes the collecting of
skulls fascinating.
But you would have
to ask Alan.
I'm more than happy to give
you his email address.
But yes, it has--
quite extraordinary.
What would you think
they might be?
I mean, that is his nose, and
you can see, when I was
referring to the very delicate
bones inside that can be
shoveled aside by these
very hungry maggots.
But those things, which you
can see right through.
I know, I'm sure there's
something to do with--
here's a cop out.
I'm sure there's something
to do with sinuses.
But yes, I mean, they lead right
into the eye sockets.
I wonder if other animals
have them.
Let's go something else,
and see if--
How about a black bear?
Yes he does.
They all have them.
Well, there we are.
This is extraordinary.
AUDIENCE: We don't have them.
SIMON WINCHESTER: We don't?
Are you sure?
Let's go and have a look
at a human, see if--
there's one in art,
isn't in science.
In fact, there's me.
Yeah, we do.
We do.
Well, you've foxed me.
But I shall find out
immediately.
You can press yours, but I
wouldn't if I were you.
Something terrible may happen.
Something else that I
possibly can answer?
That would be nice.
Right, well, in that
case, thank you so
much for coming along.
And I'm now going to, with
my wife, take part
in your lovely cafeteria.
So thank you.
It's lovely to have been here.